bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct pour cette dernière émission de
la saison on va revenir dans le détail
sur cette année parlementaire si
particulière avec vous Etienne au lion
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir vous êtes sociologue vous
connaissez très bien le Palais Bourbon
vous avez passé des centaines d'heures à
l'Assemblée nationale à scruter analyser
les profils les comportements des
députés vous l'avez fait il y a 5 ans
mais vous le faites encore pour cette
nouvelle législature alors cette
nouvelle Assemblée peut-elle fonctionner
encore comme ça pendant quatre ans il
faudra-t-il dissoudre vous nous le direz
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
mais on commence ce soir avec les 100
jours c'est le calendrier que c'était
donné Emmanuel Macron pour relancer son
quinquennat en y gai la page des
retraites semble tourner mais la crise
des émeutes a tout balayé alors comment
rebondir le président de la République
ne parlera pas demain pour le 14 juillet
mais dans les prochains jours peut-il
reprendre la main grande débat avec mes
invités dans un instant avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis Bourbon Express un peu
spécial vous allez le voir en fin
d'émission avec Elsa mon dingava voilà
pour le programme vous me suivez on y va
Etienne au Lyon ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
alors à quoi ont-ils servi c'est son
jour Emmanuel Macron au sortir de la
crise des retraites voulaient apaiser le
pays c'est complètement raté les émeutes
urbaines d'il y a deux semaines ont tous
offre lancé son quinquennat comment
rebondir quand la situation politique du
pays semble si difficile voire bloqué
bonsoir Christophe Barbier bonsoir ravi
de vous retrouver éditorialiste
politique à frontièreur et à BFM TV
bonsoir Catherine tricot bienvenue à
directrice des éditions à la revue
regard bonsoir philippe Moreau ravi de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
communicant mcbg bonsoir conseil et
bonsoir celui que je suis ravie
d'accueillir c'est Thomas des prés que
l'on connaît très bien ici à la Chaîne
Parlementaire vous êtes journaliste
politique à RTL en charge du suivi de
l'Élysée j'espère que vous avez des
infos toutes fraîches et évidemment
voilà toute confirmée Étienne au lion
votre regard nous intéresse de
sociologue bien évidemment dans ce débat
donc n'hésitez pas à intervenir ou même
interroger nos invités on commence par
planter le décor avec lami Stéphane
blackovski Macron 100 jours après le
chrono de Blacko tout de suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir à
toutes et tous alors 100 jours alors on
commence par un flash-back souvenez-vous
c'était il y a exactement 87 jours nous
étions donc le 17 avril 2023 le
président venait de promulguer la loi
sur la réforme des retraites et il s'est
adressé aux Français en réécoute et le
14 juillet prochain doit nous permettre
de faire un premier bilan nous avons
devant nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unités
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France alors évidemment cette semaine
lors des questions gouvernement le
rassemblement national ne s'est pas
privé de faire remarquer que en matière
d'apaisement ces derniers jours
n'étaient pas très apaisés enfin moi
j'emploie un euphémisme ce qui n'est pas
la figure de style préféré du lien Odoul
on l'écoute
alors que vous aviez promis 100 jours
d'apaisement les Français ont subi cinq
nuits de chaos et de terreur de fait
c'est un peu délicat de parler
d'apaisement pour le président dès lors
qu'il a dû reporter son allocution du 14
juillet de crainte que de nouvelles
émeutes n'éclatent toujours de la fête
nationale mais bon si on se sentait en
calendrier la fin des 100 jours c'est le
26 juillet donc sans doute que d'ici là
le président aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer alors revenons-en au 17 avril
à l'époque le principal objectif du
président c'était avant tout de tourner
la page des retraites donc il avait
lancé trois chantiers pour occuper des
100 jours premièrement et bien le
travail deuxièmement c'était la justice
et le maintien de l'ordre et
troisièmement le progrès alors c'était
pas gagné parce que souvenez-vous
comment ça avait réagi à l'époque côté
EFI et CGT on avait lancé les casseroles
et côté CFDT on a l'air réclamé un délai
de décence pour reprendre les
négociations avec le gouvernement donc
c'était cool les 87 jours depuis qu'est
ce qui a changé pas mal de choses déjà
les on en faisant plus trop parler faut
dire que les chaînes info d'autres trucs
à filmer que des gens qui tapent sur des
casseroles donc évidemment c'est moins
facile de passer à la télé et puis du
côté de la CFDT ben il y a eu un
changement aussi c'est qu'on s'est remis
la table de la négociation c'est-à-dire
que le résultat c'est qu'il y avait
quand même une unité syndicale qui était
incarnée d'un côté par Marc enfin
Martinez et Laurent verger puis il y a
eu du changement et l'unité elle est
moins là dernier exemple en date hier
tout simplement vous voyez ce féminin de
la CGT a quitté la réunion des
partenaires sociaux à Matignon ont
déclarant cet état échec tandis que ce
matin sur France Info Marylise Léon qui
est donc elle est à la tête de la CFDT
elle disait exactement le contraire on
écoute et donc on a eu des garanties de
pouvoir nouer un dialogue à partir du
mois de septembre donc voilà ça a été
utile on a pu se dire les choses et je
pense que c'est important alors le
deuxième chantier du président
souvenez-vous justice et maintien de
l'ordre on va pas dire que c'était pas
monitoire mais bon c'est sûr que là la
question du maintien de Land est revenue
première ligne de l'actualité avec les
émeutes donc résultat pendant ces 8
toujours avoir à moins un défaut plutôt
d'avoir réussi à nous ces fameuse
alliance avec les républicains on sent
quand même que le gouvernement soit une
sa droite encore un exemple hier vous
voyez il a fait voter un abonnement
déposé par Eric sutti d'ailleurs pour
obtenir 3000 places de prison
supplémentaires dans un projet de loi de
programmation pour la justice et puis
c'était quoi déjà le troisième ah bah
oui le problème on l'avait mis en 3e
alors l'exemple qui avait donné enfin il
avait surtout insisté sur le programme
dans l'éducation nationale et il avait
donné comme exemple à la rentrée quand
un prof serait absent ce qui arrive et
bien il sera systématiquement remplacé
donc est-ce que la promesse sera tenue
bah on attend la rentrée mais septembre
c'est assez loin là évidemment vous
allez devoir de battre de la question de
la pèsement est-ce que c'est 100 jours
d'apaisement
ont été au rendez-vous bon évidemment
c'est difficile de parler d'apaisement
sachant qu'il y a 130 000 forces de
l'ordre qui sont mobilisées ce week-end
pour apaiser éventuellement envoyer des
petites tensions merci beaucoup Stéphane
je vais commencer par vous demander un
mot un mot pour qualifier la situation
dans laquelle Emmanuel Macron se trouve
Christophe Barbier un mot funambulesque
parce que parce qu'il est sur un fil
qu'il y a du vide de tous les côtés et
qu'on ne le vent souffle et on a du mal
à le voir avancer sur ce long câble
tordu qui s'appelle le deuxième
quinquennat et la Chute toujours
possible quatrième tricot un mot le
désarroi je pense qu'il s'est absolument
pas comment reprendre la main il sait
pas comment interpréter la situation on
dirait que la situation lui échappe donc
voilà
Philippe branche Chevrolet la dérive la
dérive vers l'extrême droite alors pas
d'Emmanuel Macron mais du débat
politique et public en général
Thomas deprés un mot la tonte l'attente
parce que Emmanuel Macron avait fixé
cette borne des des 100 jours ce 14
juillet on l'a encore entendu là et
finalement il l'aurait je pense aimé
pouvoir tourner la page le 14 juillet là
et finalement il va encore devoir
attendre parce que il ne peut pas
décemment prendre la parole avant la
nuit de du 14
des Français qui en général général sont
habitués à un président qui est qui est
assez peu avare de sa parole pourquoi ce
silence c'est ça peut à ce point
dégénérer là demain soir que c'est la
meilleure option de se taire en tout cas
il y a une inquiétude de la part de
l'exécutif que la moindre petite phrase
du président dans une allocution qui
aurait pu avoir à l'occasion du défilé
demain ou dans une interview à l'issue
que la moindre petite phrase Vienne
finalement embraser les quartiers et
viennent embraser les cités et
finalement relancer une série d'émeutes
où le président a finalement réussi à
s'en sortir assez vite c'est une crainte
donc finalement pour le moment l'option
qui est choisi c'est de ne pas prendre
la parole demain et éventuellement de
prendre la parole plus tard il a dit
qu'il prendrait la parole dans les
prochains jours peut-être plutôt dans
une interview à la presque quotidienne
régionale ce qui va permettre notamment
à Emmanuel Macron de mesurer davantage
ces mots même si on se souvient c'était
quand même dans une interview à la
presse quotidienne régionale qu'il avait
eu cette expression sur les non vaccinés
qu'il fallait aller emmerder donc
finalement une interview écrite et pas
forcément mais en général elles sont
quand même mais elles sont quand même
relu et elles sont quand même très
encadrées ce qui permet d'éviter le
moindre dérapage qui pourrait mettre le
feu aux poudres Christophe Barbier il ne
vous surprend pas ce silence c'est long
quand même ça fait deux semaines non
c'est un silence très surprenant parce
qu'on est fait il porte l'idée du vide
du désarroi et puis c'est un silence en
plus dans une organisation désormais de
l'exécutif ou à part le président il y a
pas grand monde qui existe Elisabeth
borne a beaucoup de mal à se relancer
après l'échec des retraites parce que
même si la le texte est passé elle n'a
pas réussi son pari politique aucun
ministre ne pèse vraiment et ceux qui
pèse joue plutôt leur carte personnelle
que une carte de de l'équipe complète
donc oui tout remonte au président
comment reprendre la main il peut le
faire on sait que ce président a des
talents de communication il peut aller
sur le terrain on peut faire des
annonces fortes on peut bousculer un jeu
politique mais ce mais ce silence marque
plus un président sur la défensive qu'un
président qui est à la veille de livrer
une grande bataille en préparant ces
atouts c'est un silence qui laisse le
champ libre à la droite et à l'extrême
droite qui ont occupé le terrain pendant
deux semaines dans une forme de
surenchère de de mesures sécuritaires
sur l'immigration également on va
reparler avec Laurent Wauquiez
aujourd'hui par petite touche sans
parler aux Français directement est-ce
que le gouvernement a déjà choisi la
droite la fermeté on le voit avec les
places de prison supplémentaires c'est
la direction
des photos de choses j'ai l'impression
véritablement que pour l'instant c'est
le seul la seule idée qui se font leur
silence le fait qu'il ne se soit même
pas manifesté auprès de la famille de
Naël par exemple montre que on ne le
sait pas ah bah non
on sait que on sait qu'il n'y a pas eu
de visite de coup de téléphone ou de
n'ont pas été reçus ni à Matignon ni à
l'Élysée peut-être y a-t-il eu un coup
de téléphone d'un ministre on ne sait en
tout cas il y a eu aucun geste politique
fait de simple compréhension et
compassion en dehors de la réaction du
premier jour où Emmanuel Macron a eu ces
deux mots c'est inexplicable alors que
je crois que c'est très explicable mais
c'est inexcusable ça c'est en effet vrai
à part ce jour-là depuis ça a été le
silence et en tout cas des seules
réactions elles ont été pour maintenir
l'ordre et d'une certaine façon j'ai
l'impression que c'est la superficialité
de la compréhension de la situation qui
est marquante c'est à dire que il
pensait qu'il allait apaiser simplement
parce qu'il allait parler d'autre chose
mais les gens ne pas du tout des enfants
ils sont pas apaisants ils sont enfin
ils ne vont pas être apaisés on va pas
leur chanter une chanson donc il faut
leur parler de choses et leur faire une
proposition sérieuse il n'y en a pas eu
et je crois que la violence de ce qui
vient de se passer montre une société
qui est extrêmement tendue et qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer calmer simplement par
des mots comme ça ou la parole Chevrolet
c'est vrai que vous êtes communicant
dans une parole présidentielle il y a
une adresse avec des mesures concrètes
pour essayer de trouver des solutions à
une situation et puis il y a un pays qui
attend et là quand on regarde les
premières enquêtes d'opinion depuis des
émeutes plus 8% sur les questions de
sécurité c'est la deuxième attente juste
après le pouvoir d'achat elle est
remontée pareil sur l'immigration ça
veut dire que au fond on est entré dans
un moment régalien comme ça quoi qu'il
arrive il va falloir sur l'autorité sur
les questions au fond de fermeté dans le
symbole au moins dire quelque chose
avant peut-être de poser la question
très très concrète et chirurgicale dans
les quartiers on est dans un moment
extrêmement conservateur on est dans un
moment qui est un moment je sais pas
s'il est régalien mais en tout cas on
est dans un moment où l'extrême droite a
pris pour moi en tout cas le pouvoir sur
le débat publicain c'est peut-être
temporaire c'est peut-être pas grave
c'est pas pour ça que Marine Le Pen va
être manifestement élu en 2027 mais ils
ont pris le pouvoir d'une façon assez
forte d'abord parce qu'ils incarnent une
forme de républicanisme par leur calme
leur façon de se mettre en scène et la
façon camarène Le Pen de prendre la
parole petit à petit mais sans faire
d'annonce tonitruante ils ont gagné une
certaine crédibilité et en fait ils
apparaissent comme la vraie droite la
vraie alternative en tout cas
l'alternance et puis ils ont pris le
pouvoir parce que les médias sont d'une
façon générale plutôt en train d'évoluer
dans cette direction on le voit avec
l'affaire Geoffroy Lejeune où il se
passe à une bataille politique aussi au
journal
politique on va pas se voiler la face il
y a une bataille politique compris au
sein du gouvernement d'ailleurs à
l'accueil au sein du gouvernement
a été reprise de voler par le président
sur le fait qu'elle avait désavoué
papénienne qui avait attaqué Bolloré
donc on voit que ce clivage de l'extrême
droite divise même l'exécutif alors on
sait pas combien de jours il reste à
Madame borne mais de fait il y a quand
même un conflit politique peut-être sur
l'affaire Papen DIY
a pris la parole dans une interview le
week-end dernier pour expliquer que
selon lui cnews et Europe 1 a été des
était une rédaction d'extrême droite
Elisabeth borne a considéré que ce
n'était pas à son ministre de donner des
brevets de respectabilité à tel ou tel
média là où ce matin en conseil des
ministres Emmanuel Macron lui a décidé
de prendre le contre-pied et de dire de
manière assez surprenante parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait parfois eu des
rapports un peu ambigus avec cnews y
compris même avec ma valeur actuelle il
a accordé une interview il y a quelques
années ce matin Emmanuel Macron de
manière assez surprenante a dit non moi
je soutiens mon ministre papendiaye il a
eu raison de prendre de prendre la
parole et d'avoir cette expression et
donc on sent bien une nouvelle fois que
même sur ce sujet là il y a des
divisions et on en parlera peut-être
entre Élisabeth borne et le président de
la République ça commence à faire
beaucoup parce que peut-être qu'il y a
un débat qui se joue entre Vincent
Bolloré et le président de la République
parce qu'il y a une histoire de pouvoir
Vincent Bolloré a pris la main sur Paris
Match et le JDD qui sont quand même des
grosses matrices du gouvernement et de
la communication gouvernementale
Elisabeth borne avait été recadré par le
président parce qu'elle avait fait le
lien entre le rassemblement national et
son histoire et le régime de Vichy donc
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron est
aujourd'hui un grand pourfendeur de
l'extrême droite parce que vraiment ça
serait très très peu la durée de le dire
pour revenir sur le rebond possible on a
bien compris que c'est pas tout de suite
on va voir comment se passe le
14 juillet quels sont les options quand
on regarde les la feuille de route il y
a quand même quelques cases cochées mais
c'est complètement impossible de faire
FIP ce qui s'est passé quand on entend
Maryse Léon de la CFDT ça ça marche
l'apaisement que Prométhée le président
c'était en grande partie en apaisement
du climat social de ce côté-là le bilan
des 807 jours écoulés n'est pas mauvais
les casseroles se sont calmées comme le
disait Stéphane les syndicats sont
revenus à la table de négociation le
front syndical est désormais divisé
puisqu'on a entendu de son de cloche
différentes et puis il y a là en effet
une feuille de route avec de nouveaux
thèmes pour des négociations à l'automne
c'est loin d'être l'entente parfaite
entre le gouvernement et les syndicats
mais le dialogue social a repris donc de
ce côté là c'est bien c'est un autre
incendie qui s'est allumé l'apaisement
sociétal là il n'est pas pour eux
de façon tonifiante qui réveille aussi
dans notre société un besoin d'ordre et
sécurité qui devient parfois
obsessionnel et qui permet aussi des
embarder idéologiques dans
l'interprétation des causes de ce de en
même temps pour répondre à ce qui s'est
passé non c'est la limite du et en même
temps c'est assez très compliqué de dire
le mercredi inexcusable inexplicable et
donc d'apparaître comme aux côtés de la
famille et puis le lendemain les émeutes
sont injustifiables et du côté des
forces de l'ordre pour les Français
c'est une contradiction c'est pas une
addition et sur ces sujets régaliens
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit le
meilleur en même temps trouver un petit
peu son angle mort son appaui et là
Emmanuel Macron doit en sortir alors
soit il en sort en versant la table
c'est en passant un pack de gouvernement
avec la droite on élargissant sa
majorité au LR c'est un peu ce qu'est ce
qui se Laurent Wauquiez quand il dit
même si ça ressemble à une sorte de
cadeau empoisonné enfin bref il peut
tenter ça le président de la République
c'est se mettre quand même en
cohabitation alors on y va justement sur
des conséquences possibles politiques
possibles c'est soit une coalition soit
une forme de gouvernement d'union
nationale mais de quoi parle-t-on
précisément la proposition la main
tendue de leur évoquée a pu en
surprendre plus d'un explication avec
Hélène mon duel et on reparle de cette
alliance potentielle avec la droite
juste après
tendre la main à droite mais avec qui et
sur quelle base ce matin c'est le
potentiel candidat LR à la
présidentielle Laurent Wauquiez qui
avance ses pions et parle d'union sacrée
mais pas à n'importe quel prix surtout à
ces conditions il revient au président
de la République de mobiliser une forme
d'union sacrée ce n'est en aucun cas une
démarche de coalition de négociation ni
de compromission mais nous devons nous
entendre sur quelques mesures fortes des
mesures comme le rétablissement des
peines plancher ou encore l'expulsion
des étrangers responsable d'acte de
violence
quand on vous souhaite discuter on
commence pas par avoir des exigences
et on parle pas de temporairement si la
volonté de discuter elle est là elle est
bien réelle je pense qu'on peut faire ça
de façon un peu plus ouverte et un peu
plus souple je le redis la main était
tendue au début du quinquennat elle a
été refusée une main tendue mais
peut-être pas assez franchement c'est
l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozy qui
l'a évoqué lors d'un déjeuner avec une
quinzaine de députés macronistes il y a
15 jours c'est au plus fort de tendre la
main à l'Assemblée cette année 64% des
textes ont été adoptés grâce au vote des
républicains mais sans programme commun
difficile de parler d'alliance ça fait 6
ans qu'on répond à cette question avec
une certaine constance voilà nous en
donner ils ont donné qui tue quand même
non notre projet n'a rien à voir avec
celui de d'Emmanuel Macron
pour l'aile gauche de la majorité ce
serait même un mariage forcé non moi je
le souhaite pas on a montré d'abord que
on pouvait voter texte par texte des
éléments ce que montrer aussi les
républicains précisément sur
l'immigration c'est que toutes les
lignes rouges qu'on avait fixées les ont
allègrement franchi donc ça démontre que
eux ne le veulent pas non plus une
droite timoré dans un contexte posté
meute alors que 65% des Français
seraient favorables un gouvernement
d'union nationale
voilà c'est intéressant de voir qu'il y
a une attente des Français
il y aura aucune forme d'alliance quelle
qu'elle soit aujourd'hui elle est
difficile à trouver elle est très
difficile à trouver parce que les
républicains n'ont pas grand intérêt à
faire de cadeaux à Emmanuel Macron va y
avoir les élections sénatoriales qui
vont arriver au mois de septembre ou la
droite peut espérer avoir de bons
résultats et rester majoritaire au Sénat
d'ailleurs c'est certain les résultats
seront positifs pour la pour la droite
au sénatoriale quelle est leur intérêt
aujourd'hui de bouger et surtout
l'intérêt général l'intérêt national du
pays ça existe souvent c'est l'intérêt
politique qui prime surtout quand il y a
des élections qui arrivent
l'intérêt politique aujourd'hui pour les
républicains c'est de rester dans cette
situation d'essayer de temps en temps de
faire des cours comme ils l'ont fait sur
l'immigration de dire voilà quels sont
nous nos propositions et d'essayer
d'exister médiatiquement ainsi si demain
un élu de droit devenait à arriver au
gouvernement ce serait sans doute la fin
des républicains tel qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui et ça beaucoup de cadres des
républicain en tête Christophe Barbier
rien ne s'offre avant les sénatoriales
tout est tout est bloqué quand Nicolas
Sarkozy dit au fond c'est à Emmanuel
Macron de temps de la main de façon
publique forte et ferme au nom de
l'intérêt supérieur du pays s'il l'avait
fait est-ce qu'il veut le faire je ne
sais pas mais s'il le faisait les LR ne
pourraient lui dire non c'est vrai que
c'est au présent de la République de
prendre l'initiative c'est lui qui était
lu donc quand il parle d'élargissement
de la majorité et de l'impression qu'il
veut engloutir la droite donc fallait
sans doute parler de quelque chose qui
soit plus d'égal à égal mais Sarkozy
ajoute aussi en privé que cette union
lui semble inéluctable parce que la
droite en effet n'a rien à gagner en
termes politicien sauf qu'en 2027 son
propre électorat peut lui dire vous avez
laissé tomber la France vous nous avez
fait perdre 4 ans vous nous avez parlé
de la retraite à 65 ans vous avez pas
voulu voler télé 64 ans vous avez
formulé des exigences impossibles à
accepter donc on n'a pas fait la grande
loi sur l'immigration que vous vouliez
et là ça va être compliqué pour le
présidentiable LR de 2027 d'assumer ces
trois ans d'immobilisme infligés la
France pour des raisons politiciennes
néanmoins jusqu'au sénatorial ça devrait
pas bouger derrière les sénatorias les
Européennes et c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour les républicains parce
qu'ils ont connu un mauvais millésime en
2019 ils n'ont pas de tête de liste
évidentes ça peut fracturer leur camp
s'ils ne reconduisent pas certains
sortants qui pourraient aller voir du
côté de Marine Le Pen donc ça sera une
élection de tous les dangers en eux pour
eux en juin 2024 Catherine tricot
élargir la majorité si je me souviens
bien c'était le mandat qui a été donné
par Emmanuel Macron à Elisabeth borne
j'espère qu'elle y arrivera
non plus donc menaçant et sceptique donc
c'est l'impasse donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans ces cas-là l'impasse il est
pas simplement d'un accord politique
avec les LR c'est que le problème c'est
qu'elle est la proposition politique qui
peut être faite qui relance la dynamique
politique la dynamique sociale la
confiance dans le pays pour l'instant
moi je ne vois pas ce que les LR ont
apporté sur la table ni une personne
très charismatique ni des personnes très
alors là j'ai les propos
les problèmes qui sont ceux du pays en
expulsant les étrangers je sais pas quoi
je veux dire c'est une c'est un signe ce
sont des signaux idéologiques c'est des
marqueurs politiques mais ce n'est en
rien de nature à régler les problèmes
qui sont ceux que nous avons et en
premier et ce qui domine qui est le
réchauffement climatique qui est en
train de de donner ces manifestations et
nationale sur la transition écologique
et plus
surprise par le résultat de 64% de
français je pense que véritablement la
France est absolument exempt de toutes
ces tensions le problème c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de proposition politique
rassemblue pour l'instant et que quand
on voit même Emmanuel Macron prendre ses
distances avec des enjeux
écologiques dans ces déclarations et les
LR très nettement donc comment on fait
pour apporter une réponse à la jeunesse
des banlieues à la question de l'école à
la question de l'écologie
ces questions là sur la table vous
enseignez Etienne au lion on a pu lire
puisqu'il n'a pas parlé le président de
la République le sujet de l'école était
fondamentale dans sa lecture des émeutes
qu'elle devait être désormais contribuer
puissamment à la formation républicaine
faire de l'école un sujet régalien en
tout cas rétablir l'autorité ça vous
semble
urgent aujourd'hui remettre des
financements dans le niveau primaire de
l'éducation et secondaire ça me paraît
être en effet le caractère exang à
l'heure actuelle de certains lycées de
certains collèges et d'écoles maternel
ça me paraît évident c'est pas comme ça
que j'avais entendu le président de la
République moi j'avais plutôt entendu
parler de jeux vidéo en fait ce qui me
paraît pas tout à fait être le diagnost
le même diagnostic mais sur le constat
sur le fait qu'il faille réinvestir dans
les services publics je pense que là
tout le monde sera à peu près d'accord
philippe Moreau Chevrolet alors quelles
sont ces options s'il ne peut pas
s'il ne peut pas faire de coalition
d'alliance il va faire des mesures où
chacun se reconnaîtra comment comment on
peut redonner un élan au fond au pays
après dans ce moment-là je sais pas si
c'est lui de le faire enfin je sais pas
s'il est pas un peu tard pour lui déjà
ce qui serait possible c'est qu'un
candidat modéré arrive à se détacher du
lot tu le perds entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire face que tous les
prédécesseurs y compris Emmanuel Macron
on fait c'est-à-dire au bout d'un moment
partir en campagne y compris contre le
président installé et puis y aller dans
la rupture dans laquelle quelque chose
je sais pas si c'est pas ça qu'il
faudrait parce que honnêtement
et par exemple pourquoi pas mais il y en
a plein des modèles qui peuvent faire
campagne après ce que peut faire le chef
de l'État c'est difficile il a essayé de
faire un grand débat enfin de refaire un
grand débat il essayait de devenir maire
de Marseille le temps d'un week-end ce
qui était très bon c'est une très bonne
séquence mais qui a été parasitée par
les par les émeutes détruit par les
émeutes il a essayé de repartir en
campagne quelque part c'est sa manière
de faire à chaque fois qu'il est dans ce
type de difficulté mais le problème
c'est que c'est autoc et là le pays a
besoin en fait qu'on lui parle de lui du
pays et ça je sais pas si Emmanuel
Macron a encore la dynamique pour le
faire il est environné de personnes il a
pas de grands témoins autour de lui de
grandes personnalités avec du poids qui
pourraient l'aider il y a des gens
coulissent il y a Bayrou qui essaye
Sarkozy même essaye quelque part tout le
monde essaye au fond de continuer ce
jeune président mais il a pas de poids
lourd autour de lui donc qui arrivait
tout seul c'est un faisable Thomas
Després un remaniement puisque on nous
en parle voilà depuis déjà plusieurs
jours il est imminent mais les hommes
les hommes peuvent
suffire à cette attente déjà pour les
femmes pour finir sur la date on ne sait
pas quand il arrive se remaniement on
nous avait expliqué qu'il devait arriver
il y a une petite semaine quand il y a
eu ces émeutes qui sont finalement venus
perturber un peu le calendrier du
président là il a un calendrier qui est
très serré il a un déplacement prévu en
Belgique au début de la semaine à
Bruxelles il doit vous invite à aller en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et faire une tournée
au Pacifique à la fin de la semaine
prochaine mais quand on parle de
remaniement est-ce que il s'agit de
politiser son gouvernement parce que je
pense qu'il y a une attente là-dessus
les ministres sont inconnus mettre des
poids lourds politiques qui incarnent
une parole est-ce que ça c'est
l'objectif oui c'est son objectif
notamment sur le l'éducation nationale
pas peine Ndiaye aujourd'hui beaucoup
expliqué qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a pas
imprimé pendant pendant cette année et
demi où il a été ministre qu'il a été
très critiqué qu'il n'a pas réussi à
prendre son poste donc peut-être essayer
de mettre quelqu'un de plus politique
c'est en tout cas le souhait d'Emmanuel
Macron pour incarner ses priorités il
parle de de l'éducation il parle de la
santé également avec François Braun qui
parfois est critiqué la justice
escarique Dupond-Moretti va rester
ministre garde des sceaux voilà les
questions pour avoir finalement des
poids lourds on a même évoqué un moment
Edouard Philippe qui pourrait revenir au
gouvernement pour devenir des crises de
l'éducation nationale il a décliné mais
on sent bien que c'est ce que je cherche
le président à chaque fois de toute
façon qu'il veut faire maniement ils
cherchent à faire des coups il cherche à
venir apporter des personnalités telles
qu'elles avaient été par exemple Nicolas
Hulot ou encore Éric Dupond-Moretti
quand il est venu au gouvernement il
cherche à insuffler quelque chose
souvent on voit que ça se solde par des
échecs ou des déceptions c'est pas des
personnes politiques faire pas peine
Nicolas Hulot ce sont pas des personnes
étaient politiques sont des
personnalités imminentes appréciées
sympathiques tout ce qu'on voudra mais
voilà quand on a un problème reproché
souvent le manque de ce que vous disais
il faut mettre des perspects politiques
moi je me dis mais qui Étienne au lion
non je pense qu'on a parlé de
personnalité de savoir en fait est-ce
qu'il faut faire avoir des gens on a
parlé tout à l'heure de programmes
est-ce que c'est un programme en fait je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose qui bloque
aussi à l'heure actuelle pour le
Président c'est que il n'a pas de
majorité il a une majorité très relative
et vous êtes très bien placé pour savoir
que ça a été quelque chose de très
compliqué au quotidien et que s'il avait
une majorité ils auraient sûrement la
possibilité de faire passer un programme
et en général quand on sort des crises
comme la crise qui nous amène à être en
plateau aujourd'hui à savoir les selles
sociales qui avaient allumé le pays avec
les retraites il y a pas beaucoup de
une politique générale extrêmement
puissant si on convoque un référendum
c'est pour saisir l'opinion autour d'un
enjeu majeur et là on a l'impression que
le président ne sait pas que sa boîte à
outils est pleine mais que le contenu de
du sac à idée évident et là il faut
qu'il se ressource c'est aussi la rançon
d'une campagne présidentielle un peu
creuse qui a été faite sur la gestion
des crises et on ne change pas de
capitaine dans la tempête plus que sur
des propositions disruptives et un
programme lumineux sans compter que les
caisses sont vides la seule et la dette
est abyssale donc pour relancer un pays
il faut aussi ça peut être des moyens
bonne réponse regardez les choses comme
elles sont et donc ça va être difficile
mais nous allons redresser les finances
de ce pays
ensuite on ira voir Marco pommier la
seule proposition qui avait dans la
campagne présidentielle finalement
c'était la réforme des retraites c'est
la seule chose qui avait vraiment marqué
les Français une fois que cette réforme
des retraites était passée y compris
dans la majorité quand on discute avec
des députés ici à l'Assemblée ils disent
bon ok et maintenant on va où qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire quel est le cap que doit
donner Emmanuel Macron ça fait je pense
6 mois qu'à toutes la description qu'on
peut avoir avec les députés ils
expliquent bon c'est pas où on va on
sait pas ce qu'on va l'hôpital
l'écologie mais ce sont des grands
thèmes c'est des thèmes il y a pas de
proposition sur ces sur ces sujets tout
à l'heure à défaut d'interview du 14
juillet et bien le président de la
République va quand même s'exprimer il
est ce soir à l'Hôtel de Brienne pour le
traditionnel discours aux armées dans
les jardins du ministère de la Défense
bonsoir Marco pommier on aurait été ravi
qu'il soit ponctuel Emmanuel Macron mais
ça n'est pas le cas donc il ne sait pas
encore exprimé on voulait scruter un
éventuel message sur la situation
nationale quelle est l'atmosphère autour
de vous
bien écoutez Myriam oui le président a
une trentaine de minutes de retard sur
le programme prévu il est en train
d'échanger avec des militaires blessés
ils rencontrent aussi des familles de
militaires endeuillés cette parole
présidentielle elle va être quand même
scruter par les journalistes car vous
l'avez dit ce sera la seule prise de
parole d'Emmanuel Macron à l'occasion de
la fête nationale son discours devrait
être consacré uniquement aux questions
internationales et de défense avec une
large partie consacrée à la guerre en
Ukraine forcément alors ça n'empêchera
pas Emmanuel Macron de se féliciter
quand même de l'adoption définitive de
la loi de programmation militaire avec
413 milliards d'euros de programmés
entre 2024 et 2030 pour moderniser nos
armées un budget en hausse de 40% c'est
forcément symbolique une veille de 14
juillet ce soir le président d'inra à
l'Elysée avec Narendra maudit le Premier
ministre indien et invité d'honneur pour
le traditionnel défilé sur les
Champs-Élysées à la clé une grosse
commande de Rafale et de sous-marins
notamment bref vous l'avez compris
Myriam une séquence positive mais qui
apparaît comme une parenthèse pour
Emmanuel Macron merci beaucoup Marco
pommier un dernier mot qui veut le mot
de la fin sur ce débat d'attente avant
l'intervention présidentielle Christophe
Barbier là quand il est sur le regalien
quand il est sur l'armée avec une loi
qui a été votée même co-construite un
peu avec la droite ça montre que sur
certains sujets il y a une possibilité
d'agir reste à trouver le même
martingale
et sur l'immigration et c'est pas simple
allez on s'arrête là bon courage merci
d'être venu tous les quatre débattre sur
ce plateau vous restez avec moi Etienne
au lion dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis avec ce
soir Isabelle Lasserre pour
l'international qui revient sur le
sommet de l'OTAN à Vilnius décevant nous
dira-t-elle pour les ukrainiens et puis
le philosophe Nathan deverne nous livre
sa lecture de Mylène Kundera des CDI
hier à Paris et puis pour ce dernier
Bourbon express de la saison Elsa Elsa
mandingava de quoi nous parlez-vous je
lance un défi aux député dire du bien
des uns des autres c'est pas facile j'ai
hâte de voir ça allez en attendant
Étienne au lion on va continuer à en
parler de cette nouvelle Assemblée elle
a fonctionné tant bien que mal mais à
quel prix vous les avez regardé de près
sont-ils si différents de ceux qui
avaient été élu les macronistes en 2017
on voit cela dans l'invitation de Pierre
Miquel Carniel et on en parle ensemble
juste après
si on vous invite des tiennes au lion
c'est pour avoir votre regard sur cette
année écoulé à l'Assemblée sur les
députés qui la composent vous qui les
passez régulièrement au crible à 41 ans
est-il au lion vous êtes un spécialiste
de la sociologie politique chercheur au
CNRS et professeur à Polytechnique vos
travaux portent sur l'état le pouvoir et
ses élus dans deux ouvrages vous avez
analysé le portrait social et politique
des parlementaires en 2022 de nouveaux
visages viennent remplacer les novices
de 2017 vous parlez d'une brute à leur
configuration mais que sont-ils devenus
se sont-ils professionnels qui de la
nupait souduren a le plus permis de
diversifier l'hémicycle comment
avez-vous vu leur comportement évoluer
de cette année parlementaire on retient
surtout le feuilleton électrique du
débat sur la réforme des retraites c'est
une réforme
c'est ça la réalité de notre système
aujourd'hui pour faire passer sa réforme
Elizabeth borne recourt encore une fois
au 49-3 sur le fondement de 49 alinéa 3
de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement de quoi pousser
l'opposition à outrance entre 2017 et
2019 c'est 33% d'accidents du travail
causant la mort en plus
un imposteur et un assassin de quoi
faire sortir de ses gonds les ministres
Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés
personne n'a craqué et nous sommes là
devant vous pour la réforme et réveiller
des coups d'éclats permanents dans
l'hémicycle
nous avons donc une question pour vous
Etienne au lieu pour éviter ces tensions
permanentes ne faudrait-il pas supprimer
le 49-3
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Étienne au
lion ce 49-3 qui semble aujourd'hui
insupportable aux Français 49.3 dont on
a fêté le centième et la cinquième
utilisation avec la loi sur l'air trade
donc une loi extrêmement symbolique donc
qui est un outil qui est un outil dans
la palette du législateur qui est un
outil légal et en même temps qui a des
défauts incroyables je pense vraiment
que pour avoir vu une assemblée 149-3 à
une assemblée avant 49,3 une assemblée
qui vit sous le saut du 49.3 c'est un
théâtre d'ombre c'est un moment où en
fait on est dans les postures on est
dans la tension on cherche à provoquer
l'ennemi et que ce 49-3 qui est rejeté
sur les traits ou c'est l'outil
constitutionnel tout l'outil en fait
c'est un système qui est finalement
assez rare qui a été inventé comme vous
le savez en 1958 pour débloquer les
situations de Parlement sans majorité
donc de ce point de vue là il fonctionne
mais c'est un petit peu comme une arme
nucléaire une fois qu'on a utilisé
l'harmonie claire dans un conflit il y a
des traces et en général personne n'est
gagnant et je pense que le 49.3 a un
petit peu la même la même aura mais
aussi la même la même conséquence alors
vous avez beaucoup de travailler sur
l'assemblée je le disais depuis 2017
encore aujourd'hui 2017 on s'en souvient
c'était la vague des macronistes la
révolution du renouvellement avec tous
ceux qui que l'on disait nos vies
issus de la société civile qui n'avait
jamais fait de politique il nous semble
que 5 ans après et bien l'exécutif
attiré le son et a décidé que désormais
le nouveau monde n'existait plus on
revenait à l'expérience on est frappait
de voir qu'ils viennent souvent de
cabinets ici ou là vous qui avez observé
cela en sociologue vous le confirmez
c'est tout à fait vrai en 2017 il faut
quand même se souvenir que Emmanuel
Macron avait à la fois fait rentrer des
novices mais il l'avait fait parce que
il avait transformé une faiblesse
structurelle la jeunesse d'un parti sans
aucun cadre et sans personne pour venir
avec lui en une force de communication
il faut renouveler la vie politique je
dis pas qu'il n'y croyait pas je pense
qu'il y croyait mais par ailleurs voilà
il avait fait ça en 2017 cette
parenthèse est terminée il y a des
novices qui se sont professionnalisés
qui sont devenus des personnes qui
savent faire de la politique comme les
autres il y a ceux qui sont partis et de
manière encore plus significative ce que
le parti est allé rechercher Vienne tous
des cabinets ministériels donc de ce
fameux cursus honorum que critiquait
vertement Emmanuel Macron en 2017 les
classes populaires quasiment absentes de
la précédente législature on fait quand
même leur apparition plutôt assez
massivement via deux grandes formations
politiques les insoumis le rassemblement
national massivement c'est une question
de point de vue c'est-à-dire qu'elles
avaient tellement disparu au moment des
précédentes législatures et en
particulier au moment de la dernière qui
avait été la lessure la plus élitiste de
tout le 20e et le 21e siècle de 2017
vraiment on n'avait jamais vu une
assemblée aussi bourgeoise cette fois-ci
deux parties LFI d'un côté le
rassemblement national de l'autre font
revenir à l'Assemblée les classes
populaires que sont les employés et les
ouvriers on est dans l'ordre de 5 6%
alors qu'il représente 50% de la
population active
mais ils avaient beaucoup disparu
pas tant que ça parce que j'ai découvert
qu'en fait 37% des députés femmes
seulement elles étaient 39 il y a 5 ans
oui c'est un petit recul un recul qu'on
avait vu qu'une seule fois sous la
Cinquième République il y avait eu un
peu une petite baisse 2017 avait été une
grande montée mais cette parité est un
petit peu en clair-obscure parce que
d'une certaine manière on n'a pas cette
grande tendance et cette grande
augmentation c'est certain et on peut le
déplorer d'un autre côté les femmes
ressemblent plus aux hommes avant on
avait des femmes qu'on faisait venir et
qui avait des diplômes différents des
profils différents maintenant les femmes
et les hommes politiques se ressemblent
de plus en plus est-ce que c'est parce
que les femmes politiques sont des
hommes politiques comme les autres ça
c'est une autre question
c'est intéressant parce que il y a les
profils on voit que ça change ça évolue
et puis il y a la pratique on a trois
blocs à l'Assemblée nationale bloc
contre blanc que tout oppose les
Français avaient un peu de données dans
cette majorité relative l'impérative de
trouver des compromis vous qu'il avait
observé
ce sont passés c'est consensus ou
vraiment le conflit il a toujours
emporté et ben un petit peu des deux
j'ai envie de dire c'est à dire que on a
vraiment eu une assemblée en
clair-obscur avec d'un côté une
reparlementarisation qui est la
conséquence de ce que vous venez de dire
à savoir une majorité relative et une
tripartition qui empêche en fait un bloc
de tout écraser et là
reparlementarisation l'a vu à plusieurs
reprises on a vu la majorité être battue
on a vu la majorité aussi être obligé
d'accepter des amendements voire même
des textes de loi quand on fera
l'histoire de certains textes de loi je
pense qu'on verra que le gouvernement
n'était pas forcément d'accord avec ce
qui a été voté mais ça j'ai envie de
dire c'est la petite partie en fait de
est assemblée de cette année ce qu'on a
surtout vu c'est une reprise en main de
l'Assemblée nationale par l'exécutif et
par la majorité qui a déployé tout
l'arsenal de la Constitution et du
Règlement de l'institution pour pouvoir
contraindre les oppositions et là
essentiellement la réforme des retraites
là et des 49-3 budgétaires les 12 49-3
les 11 49 3 budgétaires et la réforme
plus ensuite au moment de la réforme des
retraites où on a même été jusqu'à faire
des arrangements de procédure pour
éviter que la PPL la proposition de loi
des lyotes en juin ne soit simplement
discuté sur les tensions
jeu de posture parce qu'elles ont
toujours existé un de ces grandes passes
d'armes elles sont toutes dans les
journaux officiers de notre Histoire
parlementaire mais on a franchi un cap
ou pas je suis content que vous disiez
ça parce qu'il me semble en effet qu'il
y a parfois une espèce de d'oubli du
passé on se dit ah là là la tension n'a
jamais été aussi forte c'est pas vrai
vous prenez le compte-rendu officiel du
débat des années 1950 vous aurez des
mots assez peu à même entre gaullistes
et communistes et si vous êtes au sortir
de la guerre on s'envoie des des noms
d'oiseaux particulièrement vivaces le
terme même d'assassins qui a été évoqué
pendant le reportage et qui a valu au
député saint Toul une inscription
au compte-rendu avec retenu sur salaire
c'est quelque chose qui avait été
beaucoup entendu avant c'est fort
assassin c'est une intention de tuer
mais en même temps c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait aussi beaucoup entendu là où
cet assemblée est différente c'est de
deux manières d'une part elle a été
différente cette assemblée par rapport
aux 20 ou 30 ans qui était peut-être
plus pacifiés et il faudrait que les
chercheurs expliquent pourquoi et la
deuxième chose c'est de là on a aussi
des gens qui ne se supportent pas on a
des tensions qui sont tellement fortes
que c'est un ciel d'orage permanent et
ça ça change les dynamiques à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça joue sur les
conditions de travail et on y reviendra
tout à l'heure avec Elsa ont un Gava
vous vous verrez ça ça veut dire qui
aura inévitablement une dissolution
cette culture du compromis
on ne l'a pas en France est-ce que c'est
une question institutionnelle ou est-ce
que c'est une une véritable question
d'histoire parlementaire politique c'est
une vraie question de sciences
politiques que vous posez aussi c'est à
dire est-ce que l'absence de culture
maintenant pourrait faire qu'on en
aurait pas ou au contraire est-ce que si
on changeait les dispositifs
d'organisation des votes du débat alors
on créerait cette culture il semblerait
que ce soit plutôt la deuxième solution
c'est à dire que si on en venait à
réformer les institutions ou
l'institution et son fonctionnement
alors on aurait la possibilité de créer
une culture du compromis et on le voit
d'une certaine manière dans ces exemples
de reparlementarisation que j'évoquais
il est tout à fait envisageable de
pouvoir s'accorder à partir du moment où
quelqu'un ne contient pas tous les
pouvoirs dans une main et où quelqu'un
d'autre n'est pas là en train d'essayer
d'exister en faisant de l'obstruction
donc vous croyez aux procédures aux
règles du jeu démocratique il faudrait
les changer comment on parle de fatigue
démocratique d'immenses défiance
vis-à-vis des élus il y a même des
épisodes de violence on l'a vu avec le
maire de Saint-Brévin ou L'Haÿ-les-Roses
quels changement de Constitution change
la Constitution
quel que soit le nom qu'on lui donne je
pense qu'il est temps sincèrement de de
s'arrêter de voir que tous les
clignotants sont orange vif depuis plus
de 20 ans maintenant la réforme des
retraites en a rajouté encore un petit
peu puisqu'on a quand même une majorité
qui est passée en force par rapport à
l'opinion au syndicat au Parlement parce
qu'il y a pas eu de vote finalement sur
la réforme des retraites et donc je
pense qu'il est temps de s'arrêter et de
réfléchir sur les formes d'une nouvelle
constitution et qu'est-ce que ce serait
ce serait deux choses ce serait d'une
part un processus où on décide que
pendant un an deux ans on va tous se
mettre à discuter on va voter on va
faire campagne on va réfléchir on va
délibérer ensemble la méthode est
fondamentale qui est écrit qui
participent et elle est d'autant plus
fondamentale que elle vise avec ses
déclarations sur la participation à
impliquer des gens et que donc il faut
que ce soit bien au-delà d'un comité
transpartisan fait par un deux anciens
présidents de la République et trois
chefs de parties je pense que vraiment
il faut que les Français puissent se
saisir en fait des outils démocratiques
et c'est comme ça qu'on déjoue aussi les
tensions qui peuvent exister sur des
sujets plus ponctuels
ne serait-ce qu'une révision
constitutionnelle il faut les trois
cinquième des parlementaires réunis en
congrès Versailles ça n'est absolument
pas possible dans la donne actuelle
c'est pour ça qu'il faut préparer cela
et que ça pourrait être un objectif
présidentielle future avant cela au
contraire pour sortir par le haut des
crises dans lesquelles on est à l'heure
actuelle on pourrait imaginer
d'organiser deux ans de débats de vote
de votation de discussion parmi au cours
desquels
toute forme de d'outils démocratiques il
ne faut jamais penser en silo mais comme
des manières en fait de sonder d'une
manière ou d'une autre les envies les
besoins et de surtout s'arrêter pour
reconnaître le fait que la situation ne
fonctionne pas et deuxièmement faire des
propositions
de se réjouir je vois que vous êtes
sensibles à la question de la
participation de l'association du
citoyen à la décision publique les
journalistes et même les Français se
sont passionnés par cette nouvelle
assemblée à ouvrir la Constitution ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
petites phrases les quatre colonnes on
en parle moins que ce qui se passe
vraiment dans l'hémicycle alors ça c'est
intéressant je pense en effet qu'on
s'est beaucoup plus prononcé sur des
questions très techniques
constitutionnelles il y a peut-être un
effet réseau sociaux ici qu'il faudra
aller regarder mais j'ai aussi vu dans
cette assemblée où il se passait plus de
choses dans l'hémicycle les journalistes
revenir en hémicycle est-ce que c'est
une bonne une mauvaise chose je vous
laisserai en juger mais en toute état de
cause quand il se passe quelque chose
dans l'hémicycle on arrive à capturer
l'attention ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
forcément désespérer vous restez avec
moi Étienne Holly on aurait dû vous
inviter depuis longtemps sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire c'est passionnant vous
allez voir ils seront aussi passionnants
les affranchis qu'on accueille tout de
suite pour leur partie de prix
c'est à vous
Nathan de verre qui va revenir sur
l'immense romancier Mylène Kundera et
Isabelle Lasserre pour l'international
qui nous livre son regard sur le sommet
de l'OTAN commence comme chaque soir par
Bourbon Express c'est la dernière
chronique de la saison avec vous elle va
mon Agava bonsoir à vous bonsoir et pour
cette dernière j'ai décidé de lancer un
défi au député c'est pas simple dire du
bien des uns des autres vous allez voir
c'était pas une mince affaire alors vous
me connaissez j'y suis pas là avec mes
gros sabots avec Camille Suaud on leur a
déjà proposé et bien de trouver un mot
un mot pour définir cette année
parlementaire
ou passionnante
intense tumultueuse je dirais
âpre flop bruyante à l'Assemblée
nationale très bruyante une année de
tension voilà ça c'était pour commencer
et chose sérieuse après j'attaque le
défi est-ce que vous pouvez me faire un
compliment sur la majorité me dire
quelque chose de sympathique sur eux
discipliner
c'est le meilleur compliment que vous
trouviez oui on peut pas dire que la
majorité était ouverte peut pas dire
qu'elle était attentive aux proposition
des oppositions sur la majorité un
compliment
je cherche
ils sont naïfs
c'est un gentil compliment c'est le
mieux que vous puissiez faire
et parfois ils le sont de bonne foi
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire du bien
des insoumis
j'en disais du bien je serai un insoumis
moi-même donc non je peux pas en dire du
bien pas possible même d'avoir un petit
bruit est-ce que vous pouvez me dire du
bien de la majorité vous avez combien
d'heures pour que je réfléchisse
quelques secondes après ça fait trop
longtemps c'est dur hein non c'est dur
parce que c'est dur
il représente tellement bien la
Cinquième République
[Musique]
ah bah c'est le plus beau compliment que
vous pouvez leur faire c'est ça
il représente bien son achèvement vous
voyez qu'on a bien bien galéré c'est
vrai on l'a vécu ensemble le climat à
l'Assemblée il est très très tendu alors
on s'est demandé et vous en parliez dans
votre débat précédent est-ce que c'est
que dans l'hémicycle ou est-ce que c'est
partout tout le temps
les choses sont très cloisonnées en fait
au fond la presse séance
je trouve ressemble à de plus en plus à
la séance elle-même est-ce qu'il y a
toujours
des moments où vous arrivez à avoir des
relations apaisées avec la majorité je
dirais moins qu'avant moi j'étais déjà
député au mandat précédent et je trouve
que l'état de tension politique dans le
pays et l'état de tension particulière à
l'Assemblée nationale que la majorité
enfin que l'exécutif fait peser aussi
sur l'assemblée il faut le dire comme ça
et sur sa majorité d'ailleurs forcément
se propage aussi en dehors de
l'hémicycle comment ça se passe en
coulisses dans les couloirs quand vous
vous croisez avec des députés des
oppositions vous parlez quand même ou
même se parler ça devient difficile bah
c'est ça qui est triste et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète en réalité c'est que ça
devient même parfois difficile dans les
couloirs mais qu'on continue à se parler
ça me semble important parce que moi je
c'est ça l'humanité c'est accepter
l'altérité la différence et si on se
parle plus ça devient très grave alors
c'est vrai que cette année on s'est
beaucoup demandé mais finalement est-ce
que l'assemblée elle a pas toujours été
comme ça avec beaucoup de tension et je
rejoins ce que vous disiez avant puisque
c'est exactement ce que les députés nous
disent aussi c'est que ce qui change
c'est que là la tension elle est
constante elle ne retombe jamais et ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est usant pour
tous les députés de tous les bords
politiques c'est usant bah pour nous les
journalistes je pense aussi que c'est
usant pour les Français
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites il y
a quelque chose qui mérite d'être mis
dans l'équation c'est que cette
assemblée elle a une propriété
particulière c'est une majorité relative
et ça produit quelque chose que vous
connaissez bien qui est que les députés
du matin au soir sont censés être dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'ils doivent pouvoir
être là si on fait un vote qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire de faire une présent dans
l'hémicycle en permanence ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas de moments de répit on est
épuisé on finit tard le soir on commence
tôt le matin et puis il faut aussi que
les téléspectateurs sachent que
l'hémicycle a l'air très grand fut de
loin mais que quand on est dedans il est
finalement assez petit que les sièges de
son pas si grands et que quand quelqu'un
crie hurle insulte c'est parfois à 3
mètres d'écart et donc tout ça ça
produit un chaudron 16 heures par jour
parfois qui fait que les gens sont
vraiment sincèrement épuisés je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait
pas avant parce qu'on avait une majorité
absolue qui permettait d'avoir beaucoup
plus d'espace l'apaisement dont on
parlait
vous avez évidemment regardé tous les
communiqués de un sommet de l'OTAN tout
ce qui a été donné comme garantie de
sécurité il faut décrypter tout ça vous
nous dites Isabelle que c'est décevant
pour les Ukrainiens je croyais qu'il
était content Zelenski oui il a fait
semblant d'être content il était formé
content mardi et un peu plus content
mercredi mais sur le fond il n'a pas eu
ce qu'il demandait c'est-à-dire pas
d'invitation officielle et surtout pas
de calendrier précis alors évidemment
les Ukrainiens ont fait le plein de
promesses tout le monde a juré que
l'aide arriverait jusqu'à la fin des
combats mêlés promesses sont restées
suffisamment vagues c'est-à-dire que
l'OTAN promet une entrée de l'Ukraine
quand les Alliés l'auront décidé et
quand les conditions seront réunies
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ça peut être interprété de manière
différente par les Alliés la Pologne et
les Pays-Bas pensent que cette rentrée
dans le temps pourra avoir lieu à peine
la guerre terminée tandis que pour
d'autres membres parce que les membres
de l'OTAN sont très divisés sur la
question il faudra attendre de multiples
réformes et aussi que la corruption soit
complètement éradiquée alors finalement
on n'est pas complètement sorti de
l'ambiguïté de 2008 le véto français et
allemand avait en fait refermé une porte
qui venait d'être ouverte à l'Ukraine
sur le principe c'est la ligne des
États-Unis et de l'Allemagne les
réticents qui a gagné pas celle de la
Pologne et des pays baltes zelens qui
est déçu il a considéré que en fait le
projet qu'on lui proposait pour rentrer
à l'OTAN ce chemin était absurde ce
c'était son mot alors pourquoi pourquoi
la prudence des Américains la réserve ça
de Joe Biden c'est depuis le début de de
la guerre Joe Biden commence tout c'est
meeting en disant je ne serai pas le
président qui entrainera les États-Unis
dans une troisième guerre mondiale donc
Joe Biden a peur de l'escalade il a peur
que Vladimir Poutine finisse par
utiliser des armes nucléaires tactiques
il a aussi peur d'une implosion de la
Russie qui serait selon lui synonyme de
chaos c'est pour ça que depuis le début
de la guerre il calibre son aide il
donne suffisamment d'aide pour que les
Ukrainiens puissent résister mais il
appuie sur le frein quand il s'agit de
donner des avions et quand il s'agit
d'ouvrir grand la porte de l'OTAN quels
sont les risques alors les risques ils
sont de voir une une défaite de
l'Ukraine qui serait
très très néfaste pour la sécurité
européenne
on peut se demander aussi
la guerre pourrait durer beaucoup plus
longtemps et qu'est-ce qui se passera si
Donald Trump revient au pouvoir en 2024
et surtout ça c'est la grande peur de
velody mirzuelinski il a peur qu'en fait
Joe Biden quand même le patron de l'OTAN
en gros garde la carte de l'intégration
de l'OTAN pour des négociations c'est à
dire que si la contre-offensive
ukrainienne ne va pas jusqu'au bout on
pourra échanger en disant soit tu
rentres dans l'OTAN mais tu donnes un
petit peu de ton territoire soit ne
rentre pas dans l'OTAN et mais avec
Poutine on pourra on pourra décider
l'Ukraine elle on a dit que l'Ukraine
n'était pas prête d'entrer dans le temps
mais elle apparaît elle pense qu'elle
est prête à rentrer dans le temps mais
visiblement c'est l'OTAN qui n'est pas
prête à intégrer l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup merci Isabelle on termine avec
vous n'attends de faire vous vouliez
rendre hommage à Milan kunderra oui je
voulais lui rendre hommage mais je
voulais surtout essayer d'exprimer le le
sentiment étrange qui m'a investi et qui
je crois nous a tous investi en
apprenant sa disparition parce que
précisément Millan countera ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il avait disparu disparu
des mots du monde public ça fait une
dizaine d'années qu'il n'écrivait peu en
tout cas qui n'avait pas publié de
livres et ça fait en fait près de 40 ans
que il avait refusé toute existence
médiatique c'est-à-dire tout apparition
télévisuelle et qu'il se contentait de
quelques entretiens écrits mais
extrêmement rares donc paradoxalement la
disparition de Kundera et la disparition
de quelqu'un qui a déjà disparu et en
réfléchissant sur cette idée
comme je le disais il a renoncé elle
existence publique sur le tas mais que
dès le début dès son premier roman en
fait il a passé toute sa vie à critiquer
le monde public alors le monde pour le
coup du journalisme il avait des très
très violents envers le journalisme et
plus profondément l'injonction à
apparaître c'est à dire l'injonction à
se conformer à l'image publique qu'on
peut donner de soi et dans la
plaisanterie il mettait en scène cette
problématique s'il y avait un personnage
qui était Ludwig qui était membre du
Parti communiste qui envoyait une lettre
à son amante une petite blague en lui
faisant croire qu'il était trop de
skyste et cette petite blague privée
dans un cadre de séduction érotique lui
valait l'exclusion du parti et la mise
au banc plus généralement de la société
et en fait dès la plaisanterie l'oeuvre
de Kundera se construit je pense que ça
c'est vraiment un des grands fils de la
continuité pour tenter une oeuvre qui
s'est réinventer beaucoup mais elle
s'est construit sur une défense
littéraire et politique de l'intimité et
l'intimité c'est pas seulement la
distinction entre la vie publique et la
vie privée mais l'intimité poussée
jusqu'à son paroxysme c'est-à-dire
l'idée d'une multiplication de soi d'une
multiplication des visages des
existences des aides d'identités
vérifier qui fait qu'à la fin on ne sait
plus vraiment qui on est ça c'est
vraiment la définition du roman chez
Konda ne pas savoir qui on est prendre
le risque de se découvrir ou de ne pas
se trouver dans l'écriture oui je le
pense et ne pas savoir qui on est aussi
en tant que romancier c'est-à-dire que
Kundera déconstruit l'identité de ces
personnages mais il s'efface lui-même en
tant que romancier et il refuse c'était
quelqu'un qui estimait que les
romanciers ne pensaient pas ou en tout
cas qu'il pensait que c'était leur roman
qui pensait plus que et pour finir avec
ces mots dans l'art du roman qui est
sans doute son livre qui est le livre le
plus romanesque même si c'est un essai
le roman n'est pas une confession de
l'auteur mais une exploration de ce
qu'est la vie humaine dans le piège qui
est devenu le monde magnifique vous
aimez Kundera j'aime bien Kundera c'est
un auteur qui a traversé un siècle un
siècle lourd et qui a réussi à maintenir
une certaine de légèreté dans l'écriture
tout en tout en traitant ces sujets là
l'intimité du privé et complètement
rebours de notre époque sur la
transparence sauf quand il parle
l'Occident kidnappé a qui veut colle
parfaitement bien notre époque
aujourd'hui absolument voilà grand
défenseur de l'Europe aussi on s'arrête
là merci beaucoup Etienne d'être passé
sur le plateau de SCP merci à vous les
affranchis je vous dis bel été c'est la
der des der de la saison solongue Elsa
on se retrouve évidemment la saison
prochaine à la rentrée de septembre
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis un
très grand merci évidemment à l'équipe
de savouregarde qui m'accompagne au
quotidien c'est pas toujours un cadeau
Jean-Pierre Montagné à la rédaction en
chef Fanny Saliou à l'édition Charlotte
Barbaza à la programmation Samuel Boyer
à la production ainsi que mes deux
indispensables qui vont me quitter à
grand regret Elsa bennetti et Mazarine
de manga stagiaire de compétition s'il
vous plaît qui vont partir de vers de
nouvelles aventures journalistiques
merci à toute la régie bien évidemment
et à tous les journalistes de la
rédaction merci à ma patronne également
Delphine Godard ça vous regarde bien
en septembre bah d'été à tous profitez
bien et on se retrouve à la rentrée
[Musique]